hello and welcome to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly hangout every Tuesday
at 2 p.m. Pacific right here on gay spot
calm hi
having Horst I need water joined as ever
as ever pretty much now mr. Peter Brown
and our good friend Alex Andy from the
Museu the made the Museum of Art and
digital entertainment and an Oakland
California is here to join us thank you
very much Alex good to see you again
Danny ah good to see you you guys
launched a Kickstarter today yes we did
it 10:00 a.m. this morning and it's been
doing it's been new pretty Goods yeah we
were up to about 2,500 before we started
the show here of your $50,000 target
yeah as it were and this is something
that's I know near and dear to Peter's
heart it's game preservation is near and
dear to my heart after we went and
talked to you a couple of months ago um
and I think one of the most sort of most
shocking things to me Nandi when we did
I have said at a point was just how few
people there are actually preserving
what is like incredibly important things
for videogame culture like going forward
absolutely when you came out to talk to
us we were talking about the Copyright
Office and the briefing we've filed with
the e FF and I'm still in shock that we
were an institution that had to comment
on this but there's nobody else out
there who's doing this there's
archive.org there's a strong Museum of
play
there's the digital games museum down in
Silicon Valley but there's really not an
institution you know west of the Rockies
that you can go in and learn about games
and play these old games and understand
them at least not a permanent
installation as it were so what exactly
is the maze for people who've never
heard of the made is a non-profit
volunteer run video game museum we have
free programming classes for kids and
adults in technology skills ranging from
scratch to C to unity to pro tools and
Photoshop we also preserve video game
history through playable exhibits along
themes ranging from platformer games the
history of 3d women in game development
and we provide a space for community
events such as tournaments and talks
lectures all sorts of things related to
video games yeah you do quite a lot I
think when we went out I was expecting
to just see oh it's like a Museum of
games it's just gonna be a bunch of
glass cabinets with stuff that I can't
even touch or interact with but what you
do is like there's a lot of hands-on
education happening but also people can
go in and actually play games it's not
like they're just sitting
it's almost like a fridge it's like a
library absolutely it is there is a huge
library over 5,000 games and you can
play just about any of them if you want
to PC games are a little tougher because
you have to install those console and
older home computer games we can fire up
the Vectrex is plugged in for example
the Nasus plugged in I can tell you that
just about every weekend you can find a
father and son or mother daughter or
mother son playing Mario 3 or Street
Fighter 2 and these games cross
generational boundaries and people bond
over things like Pokemon so why do we
need something like the mate because
it's important to preserve our cultural
heritage I think of it as being in 1920
and somebody wants to start preserving
film this new medium of movies right and
that day and age people might have
thought it was frivolous or not so
interesting to preserve these things
maybe they're not art but today we
obviously believe that films are art we
need to have institutions that are built
to preserve and keep the cultural assets
that are generated along the way or else
that stuff is lost to history Peter I
know you collects a lot of games you go
to flea markets and you're very much
like knowledgeable in terms of like
retro like gaming history and and
acquiring this this sort of stuff I
think I was probably of the mind like a
lot of people that like video games are
different to movies because they don't
come on reels or they don't come on
vinyl like video games are digital so
like surely they'll live forever right
but that's not the case right no
certainly not I mean especially if you
look at any of the CD based games today
those products were not designed to last
I mean anywhere near forever you know a
couple decades at best when you have all
these different manufacturers employing
different you know methodologies for
producing these discs we're starting to
see discs fall apart but you know
succumbing to disc rot so over the years
we're gonna lose this stuff and and it's
kind of a similar story what you see
with games on servers companies can take
them off at any time and so we have
these these tangible products that are
sort of you know they don't have an
opportunity to stick around unless we
protect them so it's very important to
do that and the museum is a really good
way to do that and and I also think that
people backing things up digitally is
also very smart because you know some
people call it piracy I call it
preservation in some cases because
that's the only way we can keep track of
this stuff yeah it's almost like but
remember
when we talked back in May you said that
one of the biggest reasons we have
access to quite a lot of games is
because of the piracy market yeah it's
it's kind of it's an absolute it's a
shame that the only reason we have the
Atari ST game catalog is because pirates
preserved that stuff game companies
didn't preserve it most of them were
acquired and closed down you know a lot
of game companies go under very quickly
so all of these cultural relics would
have been lost if it wasn't for sort of
this crowd-sourced effort to preserve
them now I'm not advocating piracy but
certainly there needs to be an
institution that can do this perhaps us
I'm the right now there is no legal like
allowance for that it's it's an
interesting area of copyright law yes
and one of the things the reason we came
at you in the first place was when PT
got taken down like that was a very much
a situation where people like oh my god
digital things can be taken out of our
hands
I remember in 2004 when half lexie was
launched people were like Oh buying this
digitally like what if I'll in the
future a far-flung future I won't be
able to play it or think about something
like World of Warcraft's when like in 50
years time if people want to go back and
play one of the most revolutionary MMO
is of all time like there's there may
not be a method of doing it in fact you
guys have a project for when the first
ever MMO that you're trying to resurrect
yeah the first graphical MMO for
Commodore 64 in 1986 it was called
habitat and produced by LucasArts
and we have the source code for the
server and the client and we have
undertaken a year-long effort to bring
the server back it is ridiculously
complicated so I won't go into it but we
are actually you know moving along quite
well we've we've made more progress than
I had ever expected all the companies
involved from America Online to Fujitsu
to Lucas have all been very very helpful
in this and they should be because we're
preserving their heritage their cultural
assets they made these things and if
they want them preserved you know they
can work with an institution like us to
preserve them so you guys are asking for
$50,000 what what you need that money
for what is it going towards so that is
the absolute barest budget that we could
put together to move into a new new
space we have a number of potential
spaces which we're touring this weekend
we'll be updating the Kickstarter with
them but those funds are going to be
used basically to renovate the space
paint it make it you know look nice like
our current space does now and would be
used also to pay some rent a few months
worth of rent but we're hoping to become
sustain itself
over time obviously we also have to do a
lot of fundraising through donations
from larger donors as well yeah and the
spacer and now it's it's you I think
it's fair to say you've done well with
what where you are it's an old building
like when we went in to talk to you a
roof of collapsed and one of the
janitors had broken their leg yeah yeah
yeah I'm where your classroom was
actually yeah the ceiling collapsed in
our classroom because the building is a
hundred years old and it was the
original ceiling so the ceiling was made
out of cast iron and just collapsed Wow
yeah heavy yeah nobody was hurt but it's
definitely a sign we needed to get out
of the building we needed to get out
anyway because you have to buzz in and
go up the stairs we're not a retail
space right now but considering we get
you know 40 50 60 kids a weekend for
smash tournaments we've done pretty good
considering how hard it is to find us
people would say that like why do you
need to be somewhere that's like visible
but I guess the point of a museum is
that you are easily it's easy to get
there and it's easy to find it right
yeah it's a it needs to be a retail
location I don't think that the SFMOMA
would work if you had to go anywhere all
that's building it buzzin and sign in at
a desk or anything like that you know we
sort of visit viewed the original space
that were in now as a lab because the
video game music was not a thing when we
started and over the four years we've
really discovered what it is that that
people want they want Mario 3 they want
to play Street Fighter they want to see
games that maybe they heard about as a
kid but didn't get a chance to play and
they want to share these games with
their family and friends yeah I think
one of the things that kind of struck me
when we talked last time was that you
had a you did fund rise to about $20,000
years ago and you actually made that
stretch for far more than you would
originally intended yeah that basically
lasted a year and it I don't know how he
did it I still don't know how he did it
but we did you know we used tables off
of the street corners of TVs people
would put out on the curb we would grab
them and use them
we really really scrape every quarter to
get every cent out of it we but it's all
thanks to our wonderful volunteers I
mean they were the ones who helped put
this kick-started together into the
videos and everything we have a very
good dedicated group of volunteers we
always need more mmm so if people are
looking for it on Kickstarter would they
just search for the maid right now yeah
where you can go to our website the maid
org th e ma b e org and there's a link
right at the top there is also our
Twitter our Facebook I believe you guys
are gonna have a link to yeah we're good
we've got a couple of news stories I was
tweeting about
this morning as well because it is
something that's like I've definitely
was very sort of ignorant too they saw
like my catalogue of games is the the
Commodore Amiga and like you said most
of them are pirate games that I had
copies of that turned up in some games
which never made it to Ireland I mean
never made it to Europe and now I have
them like like I cherished them and not
only because I know that I won't be able
to play them in the future if I lose
them again but I guess thinking more
further ahead that other people will
never be able to play sensible world of
soccer if I don't hold onto this
cartridge for house and Peter you've
obviously have a lot of games which are
very rare you've all consoles as well is
there any like games and consoles that
you sort of have been searching for it I
just suspiciously difficult to find or
games that have kind of disappeared into
the ether of time that you wouldn't
think of sure I mean I think a good
example is if you look at sort of the
the end of a life cycle for a console
companies publish fewer copies of games
and they would like when it's really
popular and people are really ingrained
in new content so there's a lot of stuff
on older Japanese systems like companies
like sunsoft would publish very like
limited runs of their games and stuff
like that is really hard to come by now
but I actually this brings me to a
question I wanted to pose to you because
I come to this intersection of
preservation and game collecting game
collecting is on the rise right now as
both a profitable market and as a trend
like for a hobby that people are
undertaking do you think that people are
perhaps missing the the the the real
reason to get this stuff because I know
what a lot of circles when it comes to
game collecting good were like oh I have
the valuable game like you couldn't find
that I got it there's competition and I
feel like there should be more
cooperation in this regard and I and I
hate I hate that some stuff is sort of
only reserved for the people who are
rich enough to get it when they should
really be contributing to something like
made and I know I have stuff I'd
actually like to give you guys so I'd
love to you guys to my first question
and know how I and other people could
donate well first off on the donation
front we can give you a tax write-off
for any donations and we accept things
in person and through the mail we had a
guy in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania send us
over 400 Saturn games oh man nice well
he would buy lots on eBay and give us
everything you didn't want so we have
like an the entire saturn catalog of
like dating sims yeah
but when it comes to collection you know
we're not gonna say anything to stop
people from collecting right there's
like comic books people love it and
that's fine there's totally room for
that it saves a lot of stuff from going
in the dumpster but what I don't want to
see is if there's one copy and
somebody's got it like the Charlie Brown
game on Atari you know about the Charlie
Brown game on atari 2600 nobody's ever
played it because one guy has it and he
won't let anybody play it and even
though it dumped the wrongs or and
that's that's where the community needs
to work if there's something that
there's one of right we need to dump it
and make it because it's digital we can
copy it and pass it around and preserve
it but they know if somebody wants to go
out and get that box copy of Zelda or
Legend of Zelda you know that's fine
that's fun to collect that stuff you
know you and I love flea markets half
the fun is finding the stuff it is it's
true but you know it's at the same time
I feel like there are some things that I
have that I don't have the time to play
that I wonder like is this best served
here or should this be in the hands of
somebody who can actually take care of
it and then appreciate it in the
meantime
oh it's something I struggle with
because I obviously like these things
but I like them because like you say
they're pieces of our heritage that I
get to hold on to but I wish they could
be preserved in a perfect way like no
standards and we need a real place to do
that
you got a will of course if you're a fan
of video games you know this is
obviously we like to think that this
stuff is getting done obviously it's not
getting done if you guys are hoping to
reach out and look for money it's not
like it's an easy thing to do so people
can go to the Kickstarter for the made
2.0 donation if you have like a couple
of bucks to do it by all means your
backer rewards started $5 right there
yeah but you know lots of people
donating it $1.00 yeah I mean we're
putting all names on the website under
donors no matter how much money you give
and right now are you guys still in your
current Oakland office is it available
you guys open this weekend we have a big
party on the 26th from noon to 6:00
everybody's invited it's our fourth
anniversary party it's a fantasy RPG
themed party so come in costume
excellence Alex I'll you thank you for
coming in thanks for having very much
for all the work you do as well it's
obviously doing a a great service for
the video games community and we wish
you all the best of success with your
Kickstarter we wouldn't be able to do it
without your viewers no worries yeah so
get on over there and we'll stick the
and
link in the rows are right there oh look
at it right there beautiful Josh so
making it happen the maid org
head there or go to add the maid on
Twitter and contribute to our our
collective video game history
alright we'll be back in a second folks
had a lot more to talk about in terms of
videos games coming in the future
destiny the taken King about people
playing it Erte you playing it right now
is he playing right now he's not he was
there since 2:00 a.m.
playing it I don't think he slept here
he smells like [ __ ]
we're gonna get him on in a second to
talk about that we got a bunch more
stuff to talk about in relation to
everything that's happened at TGS
they'll talk about blood boring the
PlayStation 4 price drops all that new
stuff but first of all here's a trailer
for a game that I think surprises a
bunch of people at e3 this is for honor
but that bar and we're sick of all those
new hunters I've got some old ones
speaking of old ones Peter Brown
hey I was gonna go by age if we don't
know by age Erte Peter Brown Mike you're
like 12 13 13 I'm Jerry and a half
making the beer last week Oh gave them
the beers you know I mean are we gonna
tell the Internet have it before it's in
our lead you can drink from each four
enemies while rappelling through the
windows don't SWAT us because of beer
while the [ __ ] hey how you guys doing
it's been a late-night Tokyo Game Show
you guys were up you two were anyway app
recording footage from like midnight
o'clock Erik Tay you were telling me
earlier those you were like sleepy
sleepy sleepy call them all together and
then somebody said bloodborne
and your address you impressed what do
you think about the new trailer I mean
I'm excited because I didn't going into
the year did I think I was gonna love
blood-borne or play blood-borne to the
extent that I did know so like to see it
I it was on my radar like in the summer
you only just kind of fell off for
whatever reason and just seeing it's
like oh [ __ ] that's right that's still a
thing and then a lot of this stuff that
you kind of want which is like more
weapons and stuff like that is pretty
much what they showed and you can't be
mad at that trailer dude that one sword
where you like jacket into that spinning
song yeah oh yeah as well
there was a shield at one really yeah
like it was useful yeah do me off
because he actually blocked like the
dragon's breath or something so I'm like
whoa whoa whoa I thought the shield was
not a thing there's a fire bullets I
have no idea I thought like a long rifle
maybe it music see music as long as he's
doing Dark Souls 3 and he's doing this
as well and he's gotten the like
documents swapped by accident and that
is gonna be gone in Dark Souls 3 so the
thing with like some guy trips in the
hallway and it's just a mess of paper
this will work got a me to get to so I
gotta call the questions right this
trailer first of all I can ask my Hardy
about this is this set in yharnam do you
think it is it
looks like it yeah for sure I mean they
show these aerial views which that's
definitely that looks exactly like
central yharnam toward the beginning of
the game but I mean then they have these
new like the these entirely new areas it
looks like but it's called the old
hunters which leads me to believe maybe
it's a prequel Tay and I are saying
maybe it has to do gehrman he's one of
the final bosses of the game he's the
one that's kind of guiding you
throughout the game and then he turns
out you have to you know spoiler alert
he's in the game he should yeah he he
killed me a lot of times what a day but
yeah it looks a lot like yharnam it's
still that Victorian kind of horror
London looking place if they have said
that this is a this is a brand-new set
of hunters and so you won't be taking
your your old character in or anything
so yeah it's likely that this is sort of
an isolated expansion pack that you can
play as opposed to like some endgame
content and also there's a bunch of
bosses here to kind of look like they're
modified from from the first game as
well yeah yeah dart beast par let's see
there's fire now there well there's
darkness well the dark bees par looking
kind of thing god this game looks so
good I know that's awesome I forgot a
great it looked ah you guys surprised
about how much you enjoy blood-borne
like I know you're a massive fan of it
oh yeah I've been Dark Souls fan for a
few years now I'm played 1 & 2 both
twice a few times played demon souls
never finished it but blood-borne it's
probably still if not my frontrunner
it's one of my frontrunners for game of
the year so far I've got to finish you
know not to get into a game of year
conversation yeah I have yet to finish
the Metal Gear and we have a lot more
coming and there are a lot of other
great games but blood-borne was that
singular experience I had this year or
I'm like that was [ __ ] awesome I need
I played it twice I want to start a
third new game plus it's just so much of
what I love about like action games like
that it's just it tests your it tests
you it's a great challenge and
everything but it's also just so well
designed in terms of combat and
everything I love the world of it you
know there's like all that underlying
lore which I didn't really care about
but the more I played it it was like I
might as well kind of start paying
attention to this stuff and the setting
itself is awesome I know like other
games this year I've done the Victorian
lended like the order 1886 yes and the
kit come very similar to blood-borne
yeah in everyone scores like maybe or
something yeah that game was a real
piece we won't that's a game we won't be
talking about Game of the Year I
wouldn't imagine Peter I was a big fan
of blood-borne
I'd never played Dark Souls game before
I'd like attempted to on PC like wasn't
really into it played blood-borne
absolutely adored it but like you said
the combat was incredible what did you
think about up here I think the game is
fascinating like the way that it paints
the world you know encompassing so many
small details just in the presentation
alone right and then there is all that
narrative in the back end then you also
had this amazing gameplay that's in the
middle but this game pisses me off
because I suck at it and I really want
to see everything that it has to offer
and I just I wish I had all the time in
the world or at least more skill anyway
to like really get into it all it it
really does fascinate me to no end and I
think it's like it's such a great
accomplishment and it's you know I
played Demon Souls back when that first
came out and I really enjoyed that I
skipped over Dark Souls pretty much so
blood-borne is still that game that I
like really want to get back into
because I don't want this wave of great
Miyazaki games to pass me by I don't
want to be just watching from the
sidelines that's my problem to fix it I
feel the same way because when I saw the
trailer for this I was like [ __ ] I never
completed blood-borne yeah and now it's
like sitting there with The Witcher 3
and I'm still going through Metal Gear
Solid like I've just guilt I went about
I went to the beach on the weekend it's
like any metal you saw him I came into
work and people were like oh yeah what
how many hours you in and I'm like 20
and they're like what's wrong what you
playing it I haven't completed the wiki
I never [ __ ] expensive ice coming
later this year it's games like
blood-borne and Metal Gear that
embarrassed most of the games that come
out in our industry like I hey it's just
funny to me sometimes when you look at
stuff and you're like why are people
actually like betting the farm on
something like this yeah when they're
going up against games like blood-borne
in Metal Gear like more power to you for
making the effort and really trying and
following your dream but sometimes I
feel like those people should really
just ban together attract maybe
something that's really good you know
that's the thing about like the like
Miyazaki games that you know the joke is
that they'll ruin all their games for
you and that hasn't done that but it is
the most rewarding experience for me
this year so far I mean The Witcher was
long and everything and I finished it
and I felt like I really accomplished
something but blood-borne it's one of
those games not to be not to be like
contrarian but it's it is very hard but
once you really get it down and you're
patient like on the New Game+ I played
through and it was it wasn't easy by
but I was just so into the rhythm of
that combat and like that dodging and
that counter-attack and you know trying
to refill my health bar that by the
second time I played through maybe today
you could speak to this I really felt
like I'd mastered something
yeah the challenge rewards sort of loop
on that as come yeah it's it's like it's
gonna be the weirdest reference ever
it's like third-person action braid this
is [ __ ] hard anything for granted
everything and then the satisfaction
when you when you complete it is like
amazing at a you play a lot of video
games yeah I know you've played with you
know what are we like twelve hours of
you playing destiny already today and
blood-borne this expansion packs coming
out November 27th there's gonna be a
sort of special edition version coming
out December 5th packed in with the full
game will you have time for this
November 24th is like two we less than
it's exactly two weeks after 4f4 comes
out
do you think you're gonna have time to
play the expansion pack I hope so like
so here's so blood-borne was my first
Miyazaki game never played Dark Souls
never played Demon Souls loved it I
wanted to do fallout and never played a
fallout game I'll admit it shows you can
shoot me now so I know so I want to get
into that but like now that blood-borne
is like right around the corner like I
will probably just gravitate there real
quick hopefully it's a real quick I
don't know cuz like you said you're
starting over but if the bosses are kind
of the same hmm
then you might still be able to get
through it pretty quickly - like the new
stuff we encounter that we haven't seen
like some of those bosses we haven't
seen them before but unless they do
something like pretty like pretty
substantial in terms of like cleric
beast or something like that they're
probably gonna move somewhat similar so
you're gonna be able to kind of deal
with them and maybe the abilities in the
weaponry though maybe that's the
opportunity they want you to sort of
replay familiar ish bosses but you're
like you're attacking him in different
way I mean that games once once you kind
of like dig deep and like you played
several hours like Mike said you just
kind of start seeing the patterns and
you're just like oh man I can't wait
just do it and then BOOM and just stick
the arm through that first time I got
like I couldn't get the gun to work for
the longest time
was like kept hitting it too early too
late all the time and then that first
time it didn't I clicked it was like a
[ __ ] door on there like it was like
checking keys on a lock and then it goes
and it just was like the most satisfying
thing in the world and then you get it
like every single time after that as
well yeah okay I'm pretty I'm pretty hot
yeah
and that's coming out like I said
November 24th this holiday season is
gonna be amazing I'm like just gonna sit
at home eat turkey and play a bunch of
great video games
I'm quitting good year for good a good
year man he's been great you said it was
gonna be like devoid I said I'm so sorry
that's an episode of the point about me
saying how much this year's like a
snorefest nope you've got a great game
of the year at discussion it's a little
piece together this year theater it's
gonna be rough that's why Kevin left he
was like you saw was gonna happen so I'm
going on vacation in a couple weeks so I
can come in with a clear mind take the
witcher complete the winter plays
expansions let me know as well yes there
also is that expansion with roswell
great segment before we realize you know
if any more add time and let us know
what you think blood-borne the old
hunters course coming out late November
and let us know if you've completed blob
or NYADA you looking for the expansion
please put your thoughts in the comment
box below and we're gonna be back in a
second Mike and Peter you could stay
Erica the forgetting I'm bad flute
beauty go play fallout 3
he's very back yeah go play 493 naked
and gunless oh yeah I just watch your
stream that's cuz it's just it's it's
gettin the fist thing and then beating
dogs I've seen how many uh how many
times you've been stemming up yeah it's
the stim pack Jace that's all that is
don't ruin fallout 3 for yourself that's
like I had a buddy of mine who played
half-life 2 episode 2 and did the noam
chomsky run first time [ __ ] hated it
just like ruined a perfectly good
shooting experience yeah go away and
then come back we'll talk to our CEO
Dennis Joe at Peter and my boy Michael
Hardy were here to talk about some TGS
stuff we'll be back in a second but
first of all
speaking of Victorian London kind of
worked out really well here's a Jack the
Ripper trailer for Assassin's Creed
victory
I'll look on as they search in fine
the last job was such a beauty
I love my work and want to start again
try to stop me
wait did you actually play as Jack the
Ripper Anna I would imagine I I'll make
an official announcement yes beautiful
Ubisoft sorry it sounds great syndicate
sorry I don't know what I'm talking I'm
still calling to Morpheus so I'm like
six months behind
I'll be seeing Morpheus until next year
you play Jack the Ripper I don't go just
murdered prostitutes I did Excel cut out
their bits they never figured out who he
was you know it ends in previous
Assassin's Creed DLCs you don't like
play as the villain ever from what I can
recollect but then is it just one
assassin you just find Jack Tripper and
kill him and that's it maybe it's like
you're probably always looking for him
and you can't find him where is he mmm
this line of dead prostitutes might
bring me to him and then you find them
it wasn't about face for Assassin's
Creed though if you spent the entire
game looking for your target and you
couldn't find him
oh oh yeah cuz they wouldn't know but
they wouldn't ever I do that history and
that's the screen game either would they
killing the Pope I want to know if you
please doctor I should have looked that
up I didn't see that trailer so I shot
yeah John can we get Giancarlo very Nene
on the blower is on the blower you know
horn it's Victorian England on a blah
why this is Jack Tripper they use
blowers in Whitechapel I could like a
real nasty retort to that which I will
not say on the Internet
should we talk about Tokyo Game Show
okay you think okay okay
there's no segue between dr. Ripper in
Tokyo Game Show so it's kind of three
start this one oh don't worry but they
showed this last night at Tokyo Game
Show Mike you thinking about you are you
too good at this Tokyo Game Show is on
right now in Tokyo marry Kish is there
Justin hey Wald is there an X or a
Korea's technically doesn't start until
Thursday oh really
yeah this is pre Tokyo Game Show
craziness pre TGS is on right now kids
and I got Peter Brown I'm like my Hardy
here to tell us all about all about Sony
News
yeah you were here late last night is
that correct yep
look at Sony News yeah I got in 40 GS in
the state for destiny nice you're
running on fumes right now it's been
like 12 hours I got some sleep oh you
did more than tey correct but yeah took
a game show a lot Sony just kind of came
out and just showed trailer after
trailer after trailer without much
talking yes I hear and they would walk
people I was a Chewie I came out and
then said here's a trailer for this and
then the trailer played and then he came
and said here's the trailer for this it
was weird as it every time he came out
and said something he dropped the mic
every time like all the mic it looses it
simple but did you imagine if every time
he said something he did that people be
like all right we get it I would stay up
to watch it but I didn't but I watched
the news on gamespot comm today and the
first thing I saw was that there okay
the first thing I saw which I cared
about was that they're making really
sexy colored PlayStation for us Peter
you have some really nice color
PlayStation twos and stuff locked away
in your house are you excited about
Collard ps4s
no really it's not really good colors
it's not colored ps4 is it's colored
plates it's like an you're black or
white ps4 look look it looks like an
apple commercial so it must be good like
colorful look at it it's correct like
it's fine I mean I'm I'm more enticed by
the controllers which maybe there's
really no difference between one
offering or the other but the
controllers are kind of classy I'm
honest so the the faceplates
this is the HDD version of the ps4 is
not a way of title it's a weird title
but do we actually know that they're not
gonna work on the original because
they'd be alienating everyone who didn't
buy ps4 until the last month because
that version technically just came out
and it's like slightly different in some
dimensions but is it easier to take off
the the answer because it is actually
not that hard to open what's the ps4 it
sound like different to replace a hard
drive it's it's a relatively in
comparison to ps3 it's a relatively
simple procedure
yesiree was pretty easy man it's 20 so
it's like 20 bucks or so there or what
like I don't know how yen works yeah
right now it's about 20 bucks okay it's
about a hundred and ten fifty thousand
yen that sounds robust your heart
that sounds long and they're bringing
out nine sort of versions of the console
and I think there's like two limited
edition ones and seven regular ones and
then you can buy the faceplates
separately to make it whatever whatever
you want as well that's what I meant
that's what I heard
launching them as like the schools are
gonna have nine different types it's not
wrong it sounds crazy I didn't hear that
part but that sounds like the worst way
to do it let's talk about the worst way
to do is on we doing do probably about
control no no I'm talking about the it
does sound excuse you I'm talking about
the console but it's just the faceplates
that you're changing are they're not
launching the actual versions themselves
the hardware itself you can buy like a
blue ps4 no you can't buy that they buy
them at the Sony store oh really
yeah what's the only place to buy on why
is this only coming in Japan yeah give
it time it'll come back here
and so is this gonna be like PlayStation
TV and our PS Vita TV or whatever they
ended up calling it this stuff just only
gets like it's Japan like a testing
ground or do they just love their own I
guess home audience so much that they
make sure this stuff gets same they've
been doing this for years Japanese
companies typically really stuff over
there first so and I look I mean I think
if you look at the market right now in
Japan console sales are down so this and
some of the other things they announced
are kind of I think a good initiative to
bump up interest and maybe capture an
audience that wasn't there to begin with
all right let's talk about sexy
controllers who seems like so it's
coming out in gold silver steel black
and my favorite looking at crystal yeah
some like yeah what's your favorite Mike
I mean the lot of people have been
saying they like the crystal I don't
like it it kinda reminds me those cheap
Mad Catz controllers don't you talk you
all about magnetics I really like silver
you like the sub one at the black steel
black is kind of the silver one looks
too much like the white one which they
already feel yeah I can see that but
maybe if it's shiny enough gold oh yeah
I don't think I can call me pretentious
I don't think I got the whole off gold
like I would love to walk around San
Francisco without a chain almost yeah
and then just see what people think and
then start using it people would think
it looks fine cuz jerks right here right
those dude um scooter things you stand
on the black one looks like just the
regular kitchen I wouldn't have I need
to see you side by side to see you how
different that looks but the crystal one
it's like that BAM one was saying on
it's like that goofy n64 see-through one
yeah that there was a bunch of it I had
like three different ones thousand yeah
I like you got a bunch as well
yeah seed inside the controller you
don't like that no not a fact I got
maybe a little older
which I care about color a red one you
know right there's a red one away one I
don't know that's out here yet someone
got it for me as a gift mayor in Japan
Jesus friends all over the world excuse
up buy me things unbelievable I have not
seen that can I borrow it
no cuz you'll never see it again yeah
PlayStation VR that's a name that we
they probably had 50 hours worth of
meetings for which is the most basic I
like to project Morpheus I got I'd
gotten used to it
yeah yeah what about you what do you
guys think I think it'll make sense to a
broader audience oh now especially when
like the main challenge of VR is trying
to you know communicate it to the
general public who might otherwise not
spend the money and I don't know that
just [ __ ] all this yeah it means take
the blue pill take the red pill yeah
jacking into the matrix that sort of
main means the PlayStation cell the
Trinity PlayStation neo it could've gone
with any of them it just didn't get
Laurence Fishburne's sign off I guess
it's cool technology do you think when I
think about them calling it the
PlayStation VR it's like they're trying
to address that problem that you know
the Wii U sort of bumped into a little
bit where they want to say it's
something different and new but it's
like it's associated with the
PlayStation it's not just like this
wholly separate thing it's almost like
the inverted problem that the Wii U out
one of the quotes we have here is the
name PlayStation VR not only directly
expresses an entirely new experience
from PlayStation that allows players to
feel as if they are physically inside a
virtual world of the game so that's
entirely new feels like a stretch
considering you're neither ps4 and
presumably Move controllers to get this
thing to work they haven't released a
release date or anything
Peter you you follow VR stuff quite a
lot you're very much like early on terms
of oculus and things like that how far
away do you think PlayStation VR is cuz
I feel like every time we go to an event
there's like more and more station
showing Morpheus two people at a session
V or two people I think will start
seeing it pop up in stores and have like
demo kiosks for people to give it a try
it's that I'm gonna be really smart
pursuing to do that I'd say this
upcoming summer no you know summer 2016
yeah I imagine a fall 2016 launch that's
that's my optimistic outlook
if they wait much longer than that
they're gonna run into the problem of
announcing this thing too soon so you
know showing too many of the same things
too often people want to get their hands
on this stuff to get excited about it
they don't want to watch a trailer or
Schmucks like us telling them why it's
great when you can try it and next year
I'll Kinnison valve are also gonna have
versions of their hardware acts as well
for people to develop as I think they
said January now and just last November
I think some Deb's were getting it early
in November still q1 is still the deal
for oculus you know I mean Sony has the
advantage I think and for some consumers
because the PlayStation brand is more
recognizable than oculus or valve yeah
those are very meat enthusiast kind of
brands
so what Shuhei on the cover of Time
though flapping I want to see that like
I have another I guess that this is sort
of more to do with the Japanese market
dinars certainly which is that there has
been a price drop with ps4 as well if
you converted to USD and it's now at 292
dollars down from 334 sort of the sort
of piecemeal price cut you tend to see
after a year or two and most consoles
what's interesting if you actually look
at that price a lot of Japanese price
tags include tax right before the price
so that may even be cheaper equivalent
if you take the tax tickets as a new
account off as well so it's ps4
struggling a little bit in Japan just
pretty much all consoles right like
mobile gaming is a massive pullet for
them there as well yeah you've got games
like puzzles & Dragons dominating the
gaming landscape over there and you know
Xbox is selling hundreds of units per
week which is Wow nothing yeah
the 3ds is like dominating you know so
yeah I mean I think this is sort of like
the colors introducing those it's a good
way for them to stoke interest for new
consumers but I think it'd be strange if
we didn't see something else happen for
Europe and North America
you've got Paris game week coming up
maybe something I'll say something there
for Europe the PlayStation experience
coming up in December for North America
and you will hear something about that
there so this could be an indication of
Sony's you know moving across the board
rather than just in Japan but this is
Japanese biggest gaming event this is
their time to say we you know we still
matter in the global
scape so you know gives them a sense of
pride perhaps and you know shows that
Sony cares about them yeah
same reason Microsoft always do a FIFA
bundle that games coming for here
exactly
thanks Europe thanks very much Peter
Brown Mike my Hardy for coming out
talking all about Tokyo Game Show and
all the news coming out there of course
we have boots on the ground in Tokyo as
well all week so make sure you check
gamespot.com for all the latest news and
video features for stuff that's coming
out of Tokyo Game Show just before three
times the first year I've not gone ever
in your entire life yeah I'm not going
here but I get to go on vacation there
in a couple weeks I thought I don't feel
too bad about it yeah happy for those
who are there hey Mike you ever been
nope
I've been - what's the what's the e3
this year no not this year there's the
first time in three years I haven't done
III I did I've done GDC for the past
four years you do packs for the first
time this year pax prime yes yeah
actually any pax yeah that's good for
thoughts a couple more rested here I
know blitz cons gonna be out they're
gonna be on a couple of months time
PlayStation experience as well
right I rode no right down the road now
it was supposed to be on in Vegas I
thought to have that place book that for
like four years but apparently it's
gonna be here in the Moscone Center
where GDC happens so yeah and there's so
many video game events on a lot to do
and so a lot more coming and this year
in 2015 we're gonna be back in a second
though Erte is gonna come back on the
couch to talk taking king with mr. my
Hardy here but first of all let's check
out a trader for gravity days
the highly-anticipated
expansion pack for destiny the taken
king is finally out Erik Tay and Mike my
hearty you boys put in some work you
stayed here after TGS 2 a.m. played
taking King on a livestream for hours
and hours and hours I came back in this
morning you were still playing crazy
person yeah but what I want to know
about first of all is that I viewers of
the lobby finds it lobby out there I
want to know you guys had a chat last
week I believe you said the first one to
the hacks loved before he was at PAX
first one the 40 was gonna get a steak
dinner purchased by the other I see some
body language here Eric how did you get
on
I lost okay but I think at the end of
the day yes he did be me I will say that
but I think at the end of the day we can
both say that it's like kind of like not
what we expected because I think I think
in our minds we both knew that it would
or we both felt like it would come down
to like this race of like okay he's here
I'm here like if I do this or like if I
do this faster I'm gonna win you'll
figure out the fastest way to 40 or sure
yeah and like it just wasn't that at all
literally how did you get to 40 first go
ahead we both saved up a bunch of
bounties us like we filled all 16 slots
before the expansion launched so we
could turn them in right away and get
the experience [ __ ] cheese I know a
lot of people did that just so you know
think it the the the higher level just
to start playing higher level stuff and
have access to better gear but as it
turns out it was going a lot faster than
we thought
but I also had this cloak equipped that
he had but he didn't have it equipped
because he wasn't he didn't know I gave
you ten percent experience and I knew
that person oh yeah so I started like
popping the bounties and we both felt
their controller vibrating so he backed
out and saw we're level 38 oh where he
was 38 I'm like oh my god I got a hurry
and I want to turn my bounties I turned
in like all 16 and I backed out I said
level 40 and he was like he was like the
last ones the last one was a year one
bounty so you couldn't just turn it in
from the screen you actually had to go
to the person rice so I kind of set out
loud like oh [ __ ]
Bounty's and he's like oh no and then I
like oh wait I have one more I go turned
in and I turned out hit 40 while he was
kind of like Oh calming down I think so
like a matter of seconds yeah a matter
of inches yeah so that kind of do you
feel like you missed that at all I mean
I don't know it's just I think no
because I like to be honest we had this
discussion on the stream it's like the
40 number was kind of just like one
number for you to get to that you were
just like kind of you would technically
just progress through through the story
hmm but it's not really the number that
matters
yeah like so let's another day let's
talk about what matters then so taking
King first thing I want to know about is
one of my sort of gripes that I have
with destiny as I know I never felt like
there isn't much in terms of like what I
like about games gaming content story
missions stuff that's like unique I
always felt there's a lot of copy and
paste destiny so from what I'm hearing
around the office taking king he's got
some really fascinating story and
mission stuff going on so Eric first of
all whatever think about oh so first of
all just structurally how things are
like how they went about it this time is
like way better than what they've done
like previously and I was saying this
last night too that they kind of took
like a blizzard model approach with like
they did it with Starcraft recently what
they would do is you kind of get like
this lead-up to to the mission you
either have some type of cinematic or
you're you know you have your
conversation with your quest
quartermaster quest giver and then you
kind of go along collect ten of these go
do is kill not necessarily like that
anymore but uh you know and then after
your mission you would get a little bit
more story flavor on what you just did
or like what what your next steps were
yeah where some of the like so it kind
of weaves the story better whereas in
the in the past it was like you kind of
got the mission you did it you kind of
heard from dinkle and then you just kind
of like okay here's the next one so that
just made them feel more special to sort
of flesh them out in terms of like
narrative in cutscenes yeah it just
feels smoother I think and I think even
for me that I don't care that much about
the story personally like but I can tell
what they're doing and and just seeing
the little bits of cinematics just here
and there like I mean granted it's
taking the
a year to get here but like just those
little nuggets is like a big deal I
think I've seen quotes of like the first
30 minutes of taking King as a story is
like killed destiny year one yeah like
that's how good it so how much of that
is there Mike so the main thing that I
like is the characterization I mean
they're telling a story it's a very
small-scale story in terms of for
anybody who's actually gone to
bungie.net which I have not done often
but I was so interested in the lore
behind destiny because there's so many
hints at this awesome story but it
wasn't in the game there really is a
huge amount of lore just so many
different you know like wars in the past
that affected like what happened and the
traveler came okay so how they
transitioned out to actually being in
the game there through the storm not the
overarching lore as much I mean with
Oryx being the villain of the taking
he's taken King and also a hive king
it's kind of the taking themselves are
kind of this weird force that keeps
absorbing all the other factions
probably see it soon they become this
new faction that's kind of just these
spectre looking things I have new
abilities in addition to the old ones
but yeah the characterization on nathan
fillion voices Kade the hunter vanguard
leader and he's kind of the sarcastic
one of the group and he kind of takes
things into his own hands and just goes
off and you know without spoiling
anything yes just he kind of you know
paves his own route with what he wants
to do and term it's kind of how is the
story like is it is there a lot of it is
there a lot of missions does it feel
like it like in terms of hours have you
completed it yes yo yeah the story does
what took us three hours no well so once
you beat the taken King which is like
half a story you continue with tape
that's the story but you continue with
it takers which those have more context
surrounding them as far as fighting the
taken army kind of after that it's like
endgame single player cooperative story
content almost it's separate from
strikes and PvP and everything and raids
of the raid obviously but it's like
story driven missions you could do
single-player co-op I did a few single
player but a and I did a few this
morning and yeah there's there's this
good context surrounding them which I
think was lost on previous destiny
missions so you kind of have a general
understanding of why you're doing what
you're doing which is always nice to me
I'm liked hey I didn't go into destiny
for this story but it's also it gives
you the gas or you have a sense of
impetus when you're doing something if
you know why you're doing it how it's
serving the overall storyline cool so
outside of that I guess the core like
sort of three hours of like fleshy music
content what else we looking at here I
know there's a bunch of new subclasses
there's a new area as well
what like a checkbox this stuff what are
we looking at in taking King
well we've yet to see the raid which is
like the big deal of course um it's it's
always been a pretty big deal and you
know not having one in house of wolves
and then now finally having like
probably a proper one well I haven't
seen it yet but I was going to assume
because they've basically took one off
right the new area is great I think
we're we're seeing some of it here the
dread-nots it's a ship that's right
outside the rings of Saturn I believe
we're right inside them floating and the
cool thing about it is there's so much
stuff you're like trying to find like
little nooks and crannies some of them
are quests related like go find these
calcium fragments and you just you just
look around the environment and you're
like maybe there's one there and I'm
literally jumping everywhere trying to
find this stuff and that's the kind of
cool things right
there's even there was even this other
spot that I haven't confirmed this but
I've heard I've heard some stuff is that
some of these quests require you to do
things like you have to dance to trigger
the event or like there's like a sparrow
event or something's like some Dark
Souls blob or yeah exactly so then I
started doing blood-borne things I
started triggering my my point I tried
to way but you know like and that wasn't
really in destiny before I mean like
sure there were some secrets but it
feels like the dread not like the area
itself there's just so many secrets
there's all these chests it's like you
need a key of something to open this
like where the hell do I get this key
I'm like there's a numerous amounts of
things and we haven't even tried the
court of work so there's just a bunch of
stuff and a bunch of new stuff and I
think I was telling like this I mean I
know why there's so many dlcs in between
something like this like a meaty really
mini DLC this this to me is more like a
WoW expansion yeah we're like you you've
been playing the main game you playing
playing the main game and
here's your game-changer like right like
here's something new you're kind of
starting all over again and that's kind
of why I like I was going all-in I was
just like I kept playing because I was
like this is like leveling again re
getting my gear and like that the grind
is back and unfortunately I will say the
grind is like pretty grind you though so
like so someone that's casuals probably
not gonna make the raid Friday but like
you know world first people will go for
it that's what they want right and then
like people slowly get into it so let's
let's talk about the final sort of the
piece of the puzzle then obviously there
is a review in progress upon ganks well
comrade yeah right now I'm sort of
getting into a lot of what we've talked
about already and why is the funding
review not up as of yet thing sure so I
played about 15 hours of thinking a
couple weeks ago and I got to play
through the story the endgame
single-player content at least most of
it pvp maps which have been out for a
week now actually as of today people
have to pay for those now ones but I
played the strikes and everything but I
didn't play nearly enough to see how the
quest system will figure into and just
like the gaining better loot and you
know the grind this taste side would how
it will continue after that 15 hour mark
because 15 hours is not that much in
destiny and I also I wanted to go back
and play with a lower-level character so
this is my the one I started with this
morning my 34 before we went to 40 but I
will also want to there's a buff you get
you can just start a new character or
just any character really and taking
King content you need to eat level 25 so
the post-match will give you a buff that
you just pop in you automatically go to
25 and I also just want to start from
level 1 just to see how you can progress
through their quests now but also the
big thing is the raid that's a huge part
of the expansion and having not touched
it I nowhere near having like a final
opinion on the expansion as a whole do
we know anything about the raid so we
know where it's gonna be what its yeah
its islands and why's the dread-nots but
it's you're fighting not to spoil a
story stuff you're don't then yeah there
it's called Kings fall and I think it's
it's pretty public who you're fighting
right yeah let's just say the story even
if it was 3 to 4 hours I think it is the
build up lead-up to the raid yeah and
and some of the taking war stuff as well
but yeah you're pretty much gonna fight
Big Daddy
so the main thing my main takeaway so
far that's like a factual thing that I
have an opinion about is that taken King
is much better about rewarding you for
your time I think there is a grind stuff
but I think more than ever
there's still the element of luck
playing into it but I know what I'm
working for the most part and I know it
might be like a legendary weapon or a
legendary weapon upgrade but I know I'm
gonna at least get that in whatever form
at the end of because the quest tells
you so I feel much more in taking than
year one that my rewards were based less
on chance then yes Michael so many times
you would have finished something and
then just not even gotten anything that
worth your time and so I guess to that
end and we're basically looking at the
first year of that destiny what do you
think of the taken king teh as somebody
who has enjoyed destiny who's been
playing destiny for the past year is
this enough of a does it feel like a big
meaty expansion does it feel like it's
it's it's it was worth the wait
definitely worth the wait I think I wish
there were more of these and less of
these smaller ones then right if
possible but I know they can't do it I
don't think because we've had these
conversations of not enough content not
enough content right that's why there's
all these small DLCs and I get it right
but like this this expansion is like a
true expansion and I wish there are more
of these and less of the like kind of
like smaller deals yeah because this is
actually like it feels like a WoW
expansion like I feel like great I'm
looking forward to it looking forward to
kind of starting fresh even though some
people are like hating Bungie because
they're like oh my god all the time I
spent year one getting all this stuff
it's like well I guess you haven't
played an MMO before yeah because that's
really it is I'm Mike final word on what
do you think about obviously we'll see a
review later in the week but what are
your thoughts right now I'm cautiously
optimistic so far of the like 25 hours I
played total from a couple weeks ago and
today you know I just I need to see more
but I I there it reminds me of a Reaper
of souls what that did for Diablo yes
because you jump back in and we jump
back in we're getting green items like
just what were those called unique we're
just regular in Diablo there's no no
we're getting green geared that's like a
lower level gear and it was better than
the legendary gear we had so it's just
kind of like the loot is a little more
relevant and your [ __ ] I feel like I'm
constantly have a good chance to get
something that I'm gonna swap in
obviously when you get to higher levels
that's when you start doing this stuff
that like Tay loves and that I really
like the late game content but as of now
the journey there is much more
interesting cool I'm when we see review
on ganks Volcom we don't of a definite
date yet we're gonna the raid releases
Friday so we're gonna play through that
hopefully we'll try it all be ready
around them you know it's it's gonna be
a fun weekend then yes so this weekend
early next week okay cool
awesome thank you very much Michael
Hardy okay coming on talking all about
destiny as is the case for the lobby all
year round we'll probably talk again in
a couple of months for the next piece of
DLC comes out or maybe you believe the
picture you know believe they have at
least two Eric they have if the lawsuit
last week is anything to go by
at least seven more years of soundtrack
to get through so I'm sure there's no
limit yeah exactly yeah yeah thanks so
much
let us know and also could I have to say
as well you did a really good job
especially considering you guys have
been off for like 24 well hem especially
I hit my third wind you do not look at
it's like this is this is only the my
second one it's not that bad it's not
that bad you can have four energy drinks
in one day right Eric's a consummate
professional even when he's riding on
fumes
so thanks a giveaway of a Starbucks I
know I thought some major coffee brands
we don't say who it is oh sorry I put it
tastes like [ __ ] I found out it's a
mocha nasty and I let us know what you
think about the taken King if you played
some let us know if you're looking to
get back into destiny did you sort of
get off the boil and looking to get back
into it know that the the expansion and
the hype is is back now at the grind is
back let us know in the comments below
and that was our show this week that was
a long one your dinner right yeah you go
home now you know think so just found
something down destiny gotta try it
got it tooks what is it what is he so
you know how there's swords in destiny
now like a permanent sword you can
we use and what apparently yeah
blood-borne I wish
apparently there's a way to farm for
that sword so we need GameSpot needs hot
footage so you know your court footage
at home you know I could but then I'd
also have to cut it at home whereas
right now what I can do is I can record
in them give it to someone else
clever boy this is destiny speaking not
Eric - I know it's a variable ratio
schedule of Miami these T's doing a full
review now I'm gonna kidding that thing
so that's what you're doing for us today
Mike why you do impreza you taking game
for the rest a week yeah I'm writing up
something else that no yeah I'm also
very loopy but yes destiny
halo stuff coming on the next couple
weeks I receive coverage so much video
games I'm mocking together a piece about
and we talked to Jake Solomon at PAX no
I didn't interview all that XCOM - and I
bet the history of X karma stuff so
that's gonna be like a three-part p
feature kind of like the witches stuff
we did a couple months back and bad X
comes that should be fun maybe we got
another drone yeah yeah I can't wait I'm
gonna paint a bunch of X come in the
office for the past like day or so it's
yeah 2012 there's my game of the year
and oh yeah to me I was a massive fan of
the old ones enemy Unknown or I guess
UFO defense it was called over here and
that may be one of the best like remakes
of a series ever sold way more than you
were single game was unreal it was
pretty cool
and that and also editing Tony Hawk
interview didn't be finally I like how
you guys are teasing now Oh Thursday
Thursday there would be a pretty cool
interview I did with a well-known
developer okay about a game and not many
people see a lot okay so Thursday come
back and check it out right I don't even
know what that is we'll talk about that
I think I know what it is actually on
tomorrow for everyone who's watching
live John Miyagi's coming in we're gonna
play some Disney infinity 3.0 and I
believe we also have a giveaway for that
fancy new set with all the retro Star
Wars characters so make sure you watch
that as well I believe that is 1:30
until 2:30 tomorrow so we'll be back
then but we're done tonight
it's been a long show so you better let
those guys in the back get out of here
thanks to Josh Shaw Dahmer horik I don't
even I think I earned Samson's had been
today
all his destiny time is Wow let's get
the hell out of here and you could be
famed S&E let's all go play sensei I'm
gonna play XCOM you go play that's neat
I'm gonna see you guys next week take
care